we found no trace of the direwolf your grace no
we have another wolf as you will don't mean it
don't it's not pet protector of the realm this
is meant to be your shield Lord Stark a piece of
paper knowledge is power seize him cut his throat
stop oh wait I've changed my mind let him go but
losing the people you hear me the people you think
I care back when you ripped my mother open on your
way out of her and she bled today for the sake
of you there's no bigger joke in the world than
that my center is my only daughter do you really
think I'll let you sell her like a common [__]
son as a princess it's done sir no you cannot
stop it just how safe do you think my seller
is if this city Falls there mountaha pretty sore
head on a spike right beside yours get out I want
you to know what it's like to love someone to
truly love someone before I take her from you
pretty thing your [__] lovely body the
bruises will heal in time there isn't a
man alive who could devise a more painful
death for your little [__] I'd rather
face a thousand swords than be shut up inside
with this flock of frightened hens they're your
guests under your protection you asked them
here it was expected of me as it will be of
you if you ever become Joffrey's Queen if
the city Falls these fine women should be
in for a bit of a rape when a man's blood is
up anything with tits it was good a precious
thing like you wouldn't know very very good
a slice of cake just waiting to be eaten
if you have a call me sister again
I'll have you strangled in your sleep
other ones nobody cares what your father once
told you leave this wedding right now go to
the kitchens and instruct them that all the
leftovers from the feast will be brought to
the kennels your grace Queen Margaery
the Queen they were just telling you
the leftovers will feed the dogs who you will
it wasn't my son your king take him take him
by God [Music] cute Aryan kills my brother
he'll squirm his way to freedom give him
the chance I want him dead I don't serve
your brother your grace would you love him
why did Catelyn Stark set you free what I've been
wondering for months ever since that great cow
brought you back to the capital Margaery will
dig her claws and you will take your claws in
and you'll fight over him like beasts until
you rip him apart I will burn our house to
the ground before I let that happen our baby
boy said to marry that smirking [__] from
Highgarden I would do things for my family
you couldn't imagine Aryan is your family
he's not you don't get to choose I do so do
you you can choose the creature that killed
our mother to come into this world to blame him
for that you didn't decide to kill her he was an
infant disease doesn't decide to kill you all
the same you cut it out before it does small
council grows smaller enough look at my face
it's the last thing you'll see before you die
[Music]
I killed your high Sparrow and do
all his little sparrows illness
filthy soldiers because it felt good to
watch them burn I said my face will be
the last thing you saw before you died you
remember I'm ready to meet the gods what
No today you're not going to die
today if someone is laughing at
the Queen he won't make it through
the streets covered in [__] I want
to hear I want to know who they
are I want to know where they are
those of this lovely face cracking open like
a duck egg no it's just all right [Music]
[Music]
[Music] the daughter will die here in
this cell you will be here watching
what she does you'll be here the rest
of your days you will live to watch
your daughter Rhonda there was that
beautiful face cloud to bone and dust
you may not have killed Joffrey but you
killed my cellie you killed Tommen no one
would have touched that my father was
here no one would have dad never be a
little sorry about anything why not
hear it not for you hear it I told
you no one walks away from me [Music]
are you going to order him to kill me
give the order [Music]
I don't believe [Music]